This will be released on Christmas. I don't even really know when Christmas is. Like, I have to be reminded. Everyone's eating ice cream and cookies. And that is a big problem for cheese manufacturers, because apparently dry ice is used in the manufacture of cheese. You're white as a ghost. I would really appreciate if you lied down, sir.
这将在圣诞节发布。我甚至不知道圣诞节具体是什么时候。比如，得有人提醒我。每个人都在吃冰淇淋和曲奇。这给干酪制造商带来了很大的麻烦，因为显然制造干酪时要用到干冰。你看上去脸色苍白。先生，如果您能躺下，我将不胜感激。
You're going to have to cut this into the beginning, but we have to remind our viewers about the APL drinking game. Every time Connor mentioned APL during this episode, you were supposed to take a shot of eggnog. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast. Episode 5, recorded on December 20th, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we bring you a holiday special, casual Christmas chat, where we talk about anything and everything we feel like. The short version of the story is I decided after coming back from my first co-op slash internship in 2011 that I wanted to double major in computer science because I realized computer science was the future. And in meeting with the representative or whatever, administrative person for the computer science department,
你得把这段剪到节目开头，但我们得提醒观众关于APL的喝酒游戏。在这期节目中，每当康纳提到APL，你就得喝一杯蛋酒。欢迎收听ADSP播客。第5集，录制于2020年12月20日。我是康纳，今天我和共同主持人布莱斯一起为大家带来一期节日特别节目，一场轻松的圣诞闲聊，我们无所不谈，畅所欲言。故事的简短版本是，2011年我完成第一次带薪实习回来后，我决定主修计算机科学双学位，因为我意识到计算机科学就是未来。在与计算机科学系的代表或行政人员见面时，
like I said, long story short, she was like, oh, we've got this dual degree program. It involves you going to China for two years. You should do it. And then I said, sure. And then I went to China. And I only made it a year because they kicked me out. Wait, wait.
就像我说的，长话短说，她说，哦，我们有个双学位项目。需要你去中国两年。你应该去。然后我说，好啊。然后我就去了中国。我只待了一年，就被他们开除了。等等，等等。
You got kicked out of China? I mean, technically they gave me... Are you an enemy of the People's Republic of China? No, no, no. I think they'd have me back. I mean, the university I went to would definitely not have me back. Why did the university kick you out? They had a rule in their handbook that was written in Chinese.
你被中国学校开除了？我是说，严格来说他们给了我……你是中华人民共和国的敌人吗？不，不，不。我想他们还会欢迎我回去的。我是说，我读的那所大学绝对不会欢迎我回去。大学为什么开除你？他们的学生手册里有一条用中文写的规定。
And at the time, I couldn't read Chinese. So I'm not sure how they expected me to know this rule. But you had to attend at least 70% of your courses in order to write the final exam. And if you don't write the final exam obviously you can't pass um i was only attending uh like zero percent of my courses um so you so like me you two were about hey you also flunked out of a school perfect we have uh it makes me feel better about my academic uh failures just you flunked out of a school that was, you know, in China. You went to none of your classes? Well, so I started out, I showed up in like, it was like May of 2012, I think.
当时我不会读中文。所以我不确定他们怎么期望我能知道这条规定。但是你必须出席至少70%的课程才能参加期末考试。如果你不参加期末考试，显然你就无法及格。嗯，我只出席了大约0%的课程……所以你，就像我一样，你也曾——等等，你也是从一所学校被开除的？太好了，我们有……这让我对自己的学术失败感觉好多了，只是你是从一所位于中国的学校被开除的。你一节课都没去？嗯，所以我刚去的时候，大概是2012年5月左右，我想。
And I went to courses like really, I went to all of them. My Chinese like skyrocketed. And then that course sort of only went till from May till about like the beginning of July. And then I had two months off. And at that point in my life, since I was 15, um, I had always either been working or in school. I had never, I had never had any amount of time where I wasn't doing at least one of those. And so I started to party a lot cause white people drink for free in China, or at least to where I was.
我去上课非常认真，所有的课都去了。我的中文水平突飞猛进。然后那门课程从5月一直持续到7月初左右结束。接着我有两个月的假期。而在我人生的那个阶段，自从我15岁起，嗯，我一直不是在工作就是在上学。我从来没有过哪怕一小段时间，手里没有在做这两件事中的至少一件。所以开始疯狂派对，因为白人在中国可以免费喝酒，或者至少在我待的地方是这样。
And then, you know, we got back to class in September and our teachers at that point, like in the previous semester, they spoke English in the previous semester they spoke English in the new semester they did not speak any English um wait different teachers or just the same teachers but just not in English different teachers different classes yeah so completely in Chinese and like imagine taking a grammar course about new Chinese words that you don't know
然后呢，我们在9月份回到课堂，那时的老师们——在之前的学期里他们说英语，在之前的学期里他们说英语，但在新的学期里他们一句英语也不说了。嗯，等等，是不同的老师，还是同样的老师只是不再说英语了？不同的老师，不同的课程，是的。所以完全是用中文授课，就像想象一下，去上一门关于你根本不认识的新中文词汇的语法课，
in Chinese um it's not a very good teaching tactic because you're like, you know, here's a new word and now I'm going to explain what that word means in Chinese, which is already a language you're currently learning. Versus like, so everyone in that class would be on what, there was this like app called Pleco where you would type in the Chinese character and it would recognize the Chinese character
全是用中文授课。嗯，这并不是一个很好的教学策略，因为你会觉得，你知道的，这是一个新词，现在我要用中文来解释这个词的意思，而中文本身就是你正在学习的语言。相比之下，所以班里的每个人都在用什么，当时有一个叫Pleco（海词词典）的应用，你可以在上面输入汉字，它能识别汉字，
and then translate it to English. Because like no one had any idea what the teacher was saying i was a little bookworm so i would always read ahead and i knew what the teacher like i could make out the explanation but like i remember one class they were just telling the difference between like idea suggestion and like thinking or something and like one's like young g g young and like young fa and like thinking or something and like one's like young ji uh ji young and like young fa and like i just made that up like i'm that's probably all wrong um but uh like it's very subtle like the difference between a suggestion and an idea and like trying to explain that and everyone was just super confused the point being that like it was a waste of my time to go to class
然后把它翻译成英文。因为根本没有人知道老师在说什么。我是一个小书虫，所以我总是提前阅读，我知道老师大概——我能听懂解释，但我觉得有一节课，他们只是在区分诸如“想法”、“建议”以及“思考”之类的词，比如一个是“样子”还是别的什么，比如“想法”和“看法”之类的，我这只是瞎编的——我大概全说错了，嗯，但是，像这种“建议”和“想法”之间的细微差别，试图解释清楚这些，每个人都超级困惑。重点是，去上课对当时的我是个时间上的浪费，
so i stopped going kept partying and then signed up for uh salsa dance classes and basically just became a full-time salsa student i do remember i do remember that part of the story yeah and then i showed up to my elect my final exams in december of that year or january of that year and um i basically got into like an argument with like the professor because at that point i had like stopped going to class and started just like hanging out with my Chinese friends all day and like going to salsa classes that were taught in Chinese where no one spoke English. There was one guy that spoke English, but like basically everyone I'd like so I couldn't survive unless I was speaking Chinese. And like if you want to learn a language, that is the sure fastest way. Like it is basically go take a salsa dancing lesson
所以我索性不去了，继续到处派对，然后报名参加了萨尔萨舞班，基本上变成了一个全职的萨尔萨舞学生。我确实记得，我确实记得故事的那部分，是的。然后我在那年的12月或次年1月去参加期末考试，嗯，我基本上跟教授吵了一架，因为那时我已经不去上课了，整天跟我的中国朋友混在一起，去上那些全中文授课、没人说英语的萨尔萨舞课。有一个人会说英语，但基本上我接触的每个人——所以我如果不说中文就没法生存。如果你想学一门语言，这绝对是最快的捷径。基本上就是去上萨尔萨舞课，
no it's just immersing yourself in a place where they don't speak your language like very quickly you learn uh a key phrase um how was it in chinese it was like you can explain uh thank you or something it's like but basically can you explain that for me um like well booming by which means i don't understand you can like can you explain um and like and Like, well, bu min bai, which means I don't understand. Ni kei jie ze, like, can you explain? And then, like, they're super happy. Like, all the people I met in China were, like, super, super nice and always were just like, oh, yeah, yeah, sure.
不，这只是把自己沉浸在一个没人说你的语言的地方，你很快就会学会一个关键短语。在中文里是怎么说的来着？你可以表达“谢谢”之类的话，大概是……但基本上是“你能为我解释一下吗？”，比如“我听不懂”（wo bu ming bai），意思是“我不明白”，你可以说“你可……，你能解释一下吗？”然后，他们就会超级高兴。比如，我在中国遇到所有人，都超级超级好，总是会说，哦，对，对，当然。
Because, like, if you're speaking in Chinese and explaining that you just don't understand what they're saying, your ability in that language, whether it's Chinese or another language, is clearly good enough that if they choose a different set of words, you can probably understand what they're saying.
因为，如果你用中文交流，并解释说你只是听不懂他们在说什么，你在那门语言（无论是中文还是其他语言）上的能力，显然已经好到如果他们换一套词，你大概就能听懂他们在说什么的程度了。
Anyways, so like my Chinese got so super, super good. And then I showed up to this exam. And like, clearly, like my Chinese at that point was way better than any other of the students. And I just got into this full blown argument with the prof. And I was like, what do you mean I can't write? Was the argument in Chinese? Yeah, it was in Chinese. I was just because they don't speak English. So I was just was like what do you mean i can't write like was the argument in chinese yeah yeah it was in chinese i was just because they don't speak
无论如何，所以我的中文变得超级超级好。然后我参加了这个考试。显然，我当时的中文水平远比其他任何学生都要好。然后我就和教授大吵了一架。我说，你凭什么说我不能考试？争吵是用中文进行的吗？是的，是用中文。我当时只是因为他们不会说英语。所以我只是在说，你凭什么说我不能考试？——争吵是用中文进行的吗？是的，是的，是用中文。我当时只是因为他们不会
english so i was just like what do you mean i can't write the exam like you know clearly and they're like well you haven't been coming to class and i was like why does that matter like in in where i come from you don't need to go to classes you can just show up and write the exam you're like well that's against the rules and then anyways the university was like you've got two options you can either go home or you can retake all the courses that you didn't attend and rewrite the exams after having attended the courses. And I was like, that does not seem like a good use of my time. So I just went back to Canada. That actually brings up an interesting topic.
说英语，所以我只是说，你凭什么说我不能参加考试？就像，你知道的，这很明显。他们说，嗯，你一直没来上课。我说，这有什么关系？在我老家，你根本不需要去上课，你只要直接出现参加考试就行了。他们说，嗯，这违反了规则。不管怎样，校方给出的态度是：你有两个选择，要么回国，要么重修所有你没去上过课的科目，并在上完这些课之后重新参加考试。我觉得这简直是在浪费时间。所以我直接回了加拿大。这其实引出了一个有趣的话题。
So as far as I know, almost all programming languages are english-centric but um i was i was looking at some data the other day and there are a lot of you know engineers in china and in in not just in china but in countries that do not speak english as a primary language in fact i'd say probably the majority probably more than the majority of software engineers these days are like, don't speak English as their primary language. And there's probably a good chunk of those who don't speak English at all. Yet almost all programming languages are English centric. I think that that's true. Do you, do you know of any programming languages that are not English centric or that are not at least like
据我所知，几乎所有的编程语言都是以英语为中心的。不过，我前几天看了一些数据，中国有很多程序员，而且不仅在中国，在许多不以英语为第一语言的国家也是如此。事实上，我认为当今绝大多数软件工程师——可能比大多数还要多——英语都不是他们的第一语言。其中可能还有相当一部分人根本不会说英语。然而，几乎所有的编程语言都是以英语为中心的。我认为这是事实。你知道、你知道有什么编程语言不是以英语为中心，或者至少不是以
Latin centric? Um, I do not know of any, but, um, my response to your observation is that like, that doesn't surprise me at all. So like one thing that you will learn if you like travel abroad especially to um well i was in china so i can't i can't speak for other um asian countries but i've heard as much the same is that honestly like a lot of the graduate students that i met in china like their knowledge of the english language is uh superior to mine um, I many times would hang out in, like, the common areas of these sort of residences, and they would have these little exchange groups where, like, you would ask Chinese questions, they would ask English questions, and, like, the questions that I got asked about English, they'd be like, why is this not valid grammatically? And then, like, I would
拉丁语为中心的吗？嗯，我不知道有什么这样的语言，但我对你的观察的回应是，这完全不出我的意料。如果你出国旅行，尤其是去到——好吧，我在中国待过，所以我不能代表其他亚洲国家发言，但我听说情况大体相当——你会学到一个事实：说实话，我在中国遇到的很多研究生，他们的英语水平比我还要高得多。我经常去这些宿舍的公共区域闲逛，他们会有那种语言交流小组，你可以问中文问题，他们问英文问题。他们问我的关于英语的问题，比如“为什么这个语法不合法？”然后，我
read it and just be like, like i do not know how to answer that question i just know that it's not like the like the english language is phenomenally complicated and like the way you learn it as a kid half the time is just your parents saying like no you can't say that yes you can't say that and you just you develop like an intense understanding it's like a gut yeah for native speakers it's like a gut feeling where it's where you learn it you might think about it more academically it's there's an interesting analog. So my grandfather used to teach citizenship courses for people who were about to take their U.S. citizenship class. say, you know, like, he, a Native American, like, a native-born American citizen who had, you know, fought in World War II, was a veteran, he probably couldn't have passed one of those tests if he hadn't, you know, been one of the people teaching it. Because, you know, that was
读了之后只会想：我根本不知道怎么回答这个问题，我只知道它听起来不对。英语这门语言极其复杂，你小时候学它的方式，有一半时间只是父母对你说“不，你不能这么说”或者“对，你可以这么说”，然后你就在不知不觉中培养出了一种深刻的理解。这就像是一种直觉，对母语者来说，这就像是一种直觉。你可能会更学术地去思考它，这里有一个有趣的类比。我外公以前专门为准备参加美国入籍考试的人教公民课。比如说，他是一个土生土长的美国公民，曾在二战中服役，是一名老兵，如果不是因为他恰好是授课老师之一，他很可能连那种考试都考不过。因为，你知道，那
just sort of, it was just sort of an inherent thing for him. So it's like an interesting property that sometimes people that, you know, learn a language might know it better than the native speakers or might know the, you know, the, not necessarily know how to speak it better, but understand the language and understand it sort of academically better than a native speaker whereas a native speaker might just be like no you got to say it this way because that's just that's what sounds right you know it's gut reaction yeah and and so like that just it brings me to the point that uh like so out of china out of india like if you graduate from uh basically like a one of the top universities like your grasp of the English language is phenomenal so like an English is the uh it is it is the not
对他来说只是某种很自然、很本能的东西。所以这是一个有趣的特性：有时，后天学习一门语言的人，对它的理解可能比母语者还要好，或者说他们对这门语言的理解在学术上可能比母语者更透彻，虽然不一定更会说；而母语者只会觉得：“不，你必须这么说，因为听起来才对，这就是直觉。”是的，所以这让我想到一点：比如来自中国、印度的程序员，如果你毕业于顶尖大学，你对英语的掌握可以说是叹为观止。所以英语是——它并不是
it is not the most common uh language spoken as a first language but it is the most common language spoken overall um and and so like uh i'm not surprised that like when a programming language pops up even if it's even if it is popping up uh out of you know china and i'm sure there are like some i was just shared the other day a link to uh fledgling programming languages um yeah let me send this to you although at this point i feel like we should be reporting we should be recording the uh well i think this is this is the episode right this is the episode no we didn't we didn't do we no we got to start we got to do one two three clap no no this is going in the episode i want i want to drill i want to drill down on this well i actually i think that there is one example
作为第一语言使用人数最多的语言，但它是总体上使用最广泛的语言。因此，当一门新的编程语言涌现时，我一点也不觉得奇怪，哪怕它确实源自中国——我确信确实有一些这样的语言，我前几天刚看到一个关于新兴编程语言的链接。是的，让我发给你。虽然在这个时候，我觉得我们应该开始录制了——好吧，我觉得这就是这一集的内容啊，这就是这一集。不，我们还没开始，我们得击掌三下。不，不，这一段要剪进播客里，我想——我想深入探讨一下这个话题。其实我觉得有一个例子，
um of a language that's i'm not going to say popular um it's that's that's going to offend you but there is an example of a language which is not English-centric, which would be APL, right? Because APL does not have keywords. It's all symbols. Yeah? Yes and no. I mean, technically, in the dialog APL implementation, they do have some keywords like if colon and else colon, et cetera. But, like, that stuff is not considered
某种语言——我不会说它很受欢迎，那样会冒犯到你——但确实有一个例子，是一门不以英语为中心的语言，那就是APL，对吧？因为APL没有关键字，全都是符号。对吗？可以说是，也可以说不是。我的意思是，严格来说，在对话式APL实现中，它们确实有一些关键字，比如 `if:` 和 `else:` 等等。但是，这些东西并不被认为是
idiomatic um if you're dropping down into that like you're dropping down into i think i don't actually know why it was added potentially as a bridge for people from uh you know von neumann languages um but i guess that's true i mean apl what did I, I've said many times in tweets which is, people that go to Waterloo like to call it the Harvard of Canada, which is not really true. It's a very good school, but I wouldn't say it's the Harvard of Canada. But it has a very, very good computer science program. And they used to teach APL back in the day. And I know that both Kate Gregory, who for those of you not in the C++ community is a very well-known C++ speaker and consultant. And also Herb Sutter, who is the chair of the C++ ISO committee.
地道的。如果你深入到底层使用那些，那你就是在——我其实不知道为什么要加入它们，可能是为了给那些熟悉冯·诺依曼语言的人提供一座过渡的桥梁。不过我想这倒也是真的，也就是说APL——我曾在推特上多次说过，去滑铁卢大学（University of Waterloo）的人喜欢称它为“加拿大的哈佛”，虽然这并不是真的。这是一所非常好的学校，但我不会说它是加拿大的哈佛。不过它的计算机科学专业非常非常棒。他们过去常常教授APL。我知道凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）——对于不了解C++社区的人来说，她是一位非常著名的C++演讲者和顾问——以及赫布·萨特（Herb Sutter），他是C++ ISO委员会的主席，
They both went to Waterloo. And so I asked Kate if she had been taught APL or knew anything about APL and what her thoughts on it were. And she said, yeah, it's a very unreadable language. And I was hoping she would say that she loved it. But yeah, most people don't. And the point that I'm trying to make here is that people don't say Chinese is unreadable. People say that they can't read Chinese because they don't know the characters. The same way that when there's a quote about when you read a Russian poem, if you can't read Russian, you don't say
他们两个都毕业于滑铁卢大学。所以我问凯特，她以前是否学过APL，或者对APL有什么了解，她是怎么看到它的。她说：“是的，这是一门非常难以阅读的语言。”我当时其实挺希望她说她很喜欢它。但并没有，大多数人都不喜欢。我想在这里表达的观点是，人们不会说中文“无法阅读”。人们只会说他们“不认识汉字，所以读不懂中文”。这就好比有一句名言说，当你读一本俄语诗歌时，如果你不懂俄语，你不会说
that that poem is terrible or that poem, you know, is unreadable. You just acknowledge the fact that you don't speak or read Russian. And so there's this like, there's this disconnect because most programming languages look the same. When you see something that looks different, people just automatically say, well, that's just line noise, and that's unreadable. But the truth is, is that APL is to C++ what Chinese is to English. You can't look at APL and just say, oh, that's awful. I can't read that. You first have to learn APL and then judge whether or not it's a beautiful or readable language. And I think it's probably one of the biggest mistakes
那首诗太糟糕了，或者那首诗不可读。你只是承认自己不会说或不读俄语这一事实。因此这里存在一种认知脱节，因为绝大多数编程语言看起来都差不多。当你看到一些看起来与众不同的东西时，人们就会本能地说：“哦，那只是一堆行噪音，根本没法读。”但事实是，APL之于C++，正如中文之于英语。你不能仅仅看一眼APL就说：“哦，太可怕了，我看不懂。”你必须首先去学习APL，然后再来评判它究竟是一门优美还是可读的语言。我认为这可能是
of the APL community is that they haven't been able to communicate this. When they hear, oh, it's unreadable, most of the response is just that, oh, well, you just don't know APL. Like I've never heard anyone in an APL talk or in a podcast articulate like this difference that like you can't appreciate APL until you learn it. And a lot of people say, well, you know, Barry, he's passed away, but there was an APL party, a celebration of Thought, which is that, you know, if you learn this APL notation, it was originally called Iverson notation, you can learn to think differently. And I haven't even read the paper. I've read bits of it. But Barry Revzin is alluding to this paper when he said, notation is a tool of thought, dot, dot, dot, not the way I think. And sort of, I think he was retweeting some of the APL code I tweeted.
APL社区犯下的最大错误之一，就是他们一直没能把这一点传达给外界。当他们听到别人说“这太难读了”时，大多数人的反应只是：“哦，那是因为你根本不懂APL。”我从来没有在任何关于APL的演讲或播客中听到有人清晰地阐述这样一种区别：在真正学会它之前，你是无法欣赏APL的妙处。很多人会说，正如巴里（Barry，他已经去世了，但曾举办过APL聚会，即“思想的庆典”）所说，如果你学习了这种APL符号体系——它最初被称为艾弗森记号法（Iverson notation）——你就能学会以不同的方式思考。我甚至没有读完那篇论文，我只读过其中的一部分。但巴里·雷夫津（Barry Revzin）在引用这篇论文时曾说：“记号法是思考的工具，而不是我思考的方式。”他当时大概是在转发我发的一些APL代码吧。
Well, you can't say you don't think that way if you don't even know what the symbols mean. And that's like, at one point, I had thought that potentially the paper shouldn't have been called notation as a tool of thought. It should have been called algorithms as a tool of thought. Because really, each of the symbols represents an algorithm. And then it wasn't until later on that I realized that not all of the symbols are algorithms. Some of them are operators, which is basically not all of them, but a lot of the operators map to something called combinators, which exist in Haskell and they exist in something called the SKI combinator calculus
如果你连这些符号代表什么意思都不知道，你就不能说“你不是那样思考的”。有那么一段时间，我曾认为这篇论文不应该叫《记号法是思考的工具》，而应该叫《算法是思考的工具》。因为实际上，每一个符号都代表一个算法。直到后来我才意识到，并非所有的符号都是算法，其中有一些是操作符。也就是说，虽然不全是，但许多操作符映射到了所谓的“组合子（combinators）”，这些组合子存在于Haskell语言中，也存在于所谓的“SKI组合子演算”中，
that was created by Sean Finkel in a 1924 paper and then later was developed by Haskell Curry. First name Haskell for the programming name Haskell, Curry for the common word that's used for currying functions. Anyways, I've got two swans. I tweeted them out the other day that I named Sean Finkel and Curry. We should clarify. These are not actual living swans. They're little stuffed swans that are sitting next to Connor's plant, whose name I don't remember. That's the name of the plant. Oh, yeah, yeah.
该演算由肖恩·芬克尔（Schönfinkel）在1924年的一篇论文中创建，后来由哈斯凯尔·柯里（Haskell Curry）进一步发展。编程语言Haskell的“Haskell”就取自他的名，而函数柯里化（currying）中的“Curry”则取自他的姓。不管怎样，我有两只天鹅。我前几天在推特上发过它们，我给它们分别取名叫肖恩·芬克尔和柯里。我们需要澄清一下，这些可不是真正的活天鹅。它们是放在康纳的植物旁边的小毛绒天鹅，那株植物叫什么名字我给忘了。那是那株植物的名字。哦，对，对。
You don't remember Maxwell's name? Maxwell, that's right. He's insulted. Yes, I named Maxwell after Maxwell Newman, who was the computer science professor that inspired, or at least Maxwell, Professor Newman said that he inspired Alan Turing to go in the direction that he went with his career in basically developing the Turing machine. Anyways, that's a long-winded ramble on... Oh, yes, I thought at one point the paper should be algorithms as a tool of thought, not notation as a tool of thought, but the language is both algorithms and operators. Or you can read operators as combinators. Like, so for example, the Haskell flip
你不记得麦克斯韦（Maxwell）的名字了？麦克斯韦，对，就是它。它生气了。是的，我给麦克斯韦起这个名字是为了纪念麦克斯韦·纽曼（Maxwell Newman），他是一位计算机科学教授，正是他激发了阿兰·图灵的灵感，或者说纽曼教授引导阿兰·图灵走上了后来的职业道路，并最终设计出了图灵机。不管怎样，这是一段冗长的闲聊……哦，对了，我一度认为那篇论文应该叫《算法是思考的工具》，而不是《记号法是思考的工具》，但实际上这门语言既包含算法，也包含操作符。或者你可以把操作符看作组合子。比如，就拿我们在前一期节目中讨论过的Haskell的 `flip` 函数来说，
that we talked about, I believe, in the previous episode, there is a symbol in APL called commute, which is exactly that. And what's even more beautiful is that both, like every symbol is both monadic and dyadic. So if it is past a single argument, it has one behavior. And if it's past two arguments, then it has a different behavior. Isn't that a little bit confusing? Because the behaviors aren't always a natural extension of each other, correct? Oh, oh, like this is now, now we're getting into like...
在APL中有一个对应的符号叫“对易（commute）”，它完全就是干这个的。更美妙的是，每一个符号既是单目（monadic）的，又是双目（dyadic）的。因此，如果它接收单个参数，它表现出一种行为；如果它接收两个参数，它就会表现出完全不同的行为。难道这不会让人有点糊涂吗？因为这些行为并不总是一种自然的延伸，对吧？哦，哦，这下好了，这下我们开始进入……
This is now APL the podcast. Now we're getting into like secrets that i've been keeping um for future talks that i'd like to give um that like uh yes and no like many times there there is so much thought which is why i just i think ken iverson is such a genius like thought and care were put into um like the the monadic and dyadic meanings of these algorithms um what is uh an example that i wasn't planning on showing in it well you know you know what screw it if you're listening to this podcast you're getting a a a preview of what is going to be you know i've been thinking about this moment that I was going to give an opportunity. This is Connor's Christmas present to you.
这下成了“APL播客”了。我们现在开始涉及一些我一直藏着掖着的秘密，留着以后在演讲中分享。是的，其实也不是。很多时候，这里面蕴含着太多的思考——这就是为什么我认为肯·艾弗森（Ken Iverson）是个不折不扣的天才——这些算法的单目和双目含义中，凝聚了太多的思考与心血。有什么例子吗？我本来没打算在里——好吧，你知道吗，去他的！如果你在听这个播客，你就是在提前预览我一直在思考的、即将在某次演讲中分享的内容。这是康纳送给你们的圣诞礼物。
Yeah, this is a merry, yeah. Well, so I thought we hadn't started the podcast, so I don't know how we're going to cut this. But, yeah, this podcast is coming out on. That is your problem, not mine. It's coming out on Christmas. So happy holidays to everyone. This is my Christmas gift
对，这是一份快乐的——好吧，我还以为我们还没开始录播客呢，所以我都不知道该怎么剪辑这段。不过，这期播客是在圣诞节发布。那是你的问题，又不是我的。它是圣诞节当天发布的。所以祝大家节日快乐。这是我送给所有听众的
to all the listeners so there is a algorithm in APL that is a circle with a vertical line through it so imagine just like the pipe symbol with the letter O
圣诞礼物。在APL中有一个算法，它的符号是一个中间有一条竖线的圆圈。你可以想象一下，把一根管道符号（`|`）和字母 `O`
overlaying each other and what is well there's so many directions I can go with this. A small tangent is that in the original APL back in the 60s, they had like, they didn't have Unicode and all this stuff, so they had like a set of characters that were simple, and that for certain characters, you would literally have to superimpose two of the characters next to each other. So a circle was pi. And the pipe, I believe the dyadic version was modulus,
重叠在一起。接下来，我可以讲的方向实在太多了。顺便提个小插曲，在60年代最初的APL中，他们还没有Unicode和各种现代字符，所以他们只有一套简单的字符集。对于某些字符，你 literalmente（字面意思）必须把两个字符重叠打印在一起。所以，圆圈代表圆周率（$\pi$）。而那个竖线，我相信它的双目版本代表求模（modulus），
or technically the opposite of modulus, but you can just read modulus. And the monadic version of the pipe was absolute value. But if you took the pipe and the circle and overlaid them, you get an algorithm called reverse. And this is, it's by, I'm just giving so much away. Merry Christmas. I'm probably going to get an APL tattoo saying, and I'll include this stuff about hating needles, maybe. Maybe if that stuff got cut earlier, Bryce and I were talking about how we hate needles, but we're obviously still both can get the vaccine. I decided in January of 2019, roughly a year ago that I wanted this tattoo, but I had always hated the idea of getting a tattoo.
或者严格来说是求模的反操作，但你直接把它当成求模就行了。竖线的单目版本则是绝对值。但如果你把竖线和圆圈重叠在一起，就会得到一个名为“反转（reverse）”的算法。天哪，我透露得太多了。圣诞快乐。我可能要在身上纹一个APL符号，写着——顺便我还会把讨厌打针的事也加上。也许吧。如果刚才关于我和布莱斯讨厌打针的那段没有被剪掉的话（虽然我们俩显然都还是会去打疫苗）。我在2019年1月——大约一年前——决定想要这个纹身，但我一直很讨厌纹身这回事。
So I figured, you know what, I'm going to wait a year. If I still want this tattoo in a year, then I'll probably go ahead and get it. And now that I'm saying it on the podcast is basically i basically have to get it but uh so reverse we will do a podcast episode while you're getting the tattoo sure um so reverse it's it's so beautiful for so many reasons so uh first of all it is visually neonomic think about a circle with a vertical line if you imagine that you could grab the bottom so like the line extends
所以我想，你知道吗，我先等一年。如果一年后我依然想要这个纹身，那我再去纹不迟。既然我现在在播客里说出来了，那我基本上就不得不去纹了。所以，关于“反转”——我们可以在你纹身的时候录一期播客。当然。反转这个算法实在太美妙了，原因有很多。首先，它在视觉上是具象命名的（neonomic）。想想一个带竖线的圆圈，如果你想象可以抓住底部的那个线——也就是说线延伸了出来，
it's not the circle picture it not as just like a diameter but picture the line extending past the circle if you imagine you can grab the bottom of that line and twirl it that visually is reversing i i think that's reaching i think like a little you know symbol that might be like like a good visual representation for reverse no so but here's the
不要把那个圆圈仅仅看作一个直径，而是想象线延伸穿过了圆圈——如果你想象自己能抓住那条线的底部并转动它，这在视觉上就代表着反转。我觉得这有点牵强。我觉得那种符号可能算是一个不错的“反转”视觉表征吧？不，但关键是，
thing here's the thing maybe by itself you might be like, ah, that's a stretch. Until you realize there's another algorithm called transpose, which is a circle with a slash through it. And what do you do when you transpose a matrix? You twirl it once again by where the line is. Yeah. And there's another algorithm, which is a horizontal reverse. So if you have a rank one matrix, which is just a vector, it doesn't do anything. You can't horizontally.
关键是，也许单看这个符号，你会觉得：啊，这有点勉强。直到你意识到，还有另一个叫做“转置（transpose）”的算法，它是一个带斜线的圆圈。当你对矩阵进行转置时，你在做什么？你也是沿着那条线所在的位置把它旋转一下。是的。还有一个算法，是水平反转。如果你有一个一维矩阵（也就是向量），它什么也不做，你没法进行水平反转。
You can only sort of vertically reverse that. But if you have a matrix, you can both horizontally reverse it. So like row wise reverse, or you can column-wise reverse. Well, there are three symbols. Each of them is a circle with a line through it. The line represents basically the plane that you are mutating your two-rank matrix, which is so – When I started learning APL, I didn't realize that like they were visual representations of the mutation that you were making to your vector or matrix.
你只能对它进行某种垂直反转。但如果你有一个二维矩阵，你既可以对它进行水平反转（也就是按行反转），也可以进行垂直反转（按列反转）。这里有三个符号，它们都是一个带线的圆圈。这条线基本上代表了你对二阶矩阵进行变换时所依据的平面。所以——当我刚开始学习APL时，我并没有意识到它们其实就是对向量或矩阵所做变换的视觉表征。
And then when I realized it, I was like, what? Like, this is so beautiful. It's so beautiful. And like once you see it, you are never going to forget it. You don't need to know the name of reverse or transpose. It is a visual representation of the way that you are mutating like your data. And this is just the start. Your original question was, it's probably, like, isn't it confusing to have an overloading based on the number of arguments? Because there's
而当我意识到这一点的瞬间，我惊呆了：天哪，这太美妙了！简直太美妙了。一旦你明白了这一点，你就永远不会忘记它。你甚至不需要记住“反转”或“转置”的名字，它本身就是你对数据进行变换方式的直观视觉呈现。而这仅仅是个开始。你最初的问题是：根据参数数量来进行函数重载，难道不会让人感到混乱吗？因为单目版本和双目版本之间
probably not a relationship between the monadic version and the dyadic. So here we go. Here we go, Bryce. You're not going to know the answer to this question, but I'm going to ask it anyways, and our listeners can listen along. What do you think the dyadic version of the reverse glyph is? So like the same symbol that takes two arguments. Could you guess? And I'll give you a hint. It exists in the C++ algorithm header. The same way that reverse exists in the C++ algorithm header. All right, give me a second. So what is a natural extension of reverse? Well, it's an algorithm which takes two input sequences.
可能并没有什么直观的联系。所以，听好了，布莱斯。你肯定猜不到这个问题的答案，但我还是要问，我们的听众也可以一起来猜猜看。你觉得“反转”这个符号的双目版本是什么意思？也就是说，同一个符号接收两个参数时代表什么？你能猜到吗？我给你个提示：它存在于C++的 `` 头文件中。就像 `reverse` 存在于C++算法头文件中一样。好吧，让我想一会儿。那么，什么是反转的一种自然延伸呢？嗯，它是一个接收两个输入序列的算法。
So that narrows it down. It actually, I'll give you a hint. It doesn't take two input sequences. So that narrows it down a little bit. Actually, I'll give you a hint. It doesn't take two input sequences. It's an algorithm that takes three iterators. Three iterators. On the same range. Wait, three begin iterators or begin, end, and begin? Begin, one in the middle, and one at the end.
这把范围缩小了。其实，我再给你个提示：它不接收两个输入序列。好吧，这又把范围缩小了一点。实际上，我再给你个提示：它不接收两个输入序列。它是一个接收三个迭代器的算法。三个迭代器。在同一个区间上。等等，是三个起始迭代器，还是一个起始、一个结束、一个在中间？一个起始，一个在中间，一个在结束。
And that should really narrow it down. Wait, partition? Partition? one in the middle and one at the end. And that should really narrow it down. Wait, partition? Partition takes two iterators plus a unary predicate. In fact, I can only think of two algorithms at the moment that take a begin, an end, and something in the middle. Hang on. I got to pull up the list at least. If you're listening along,
这应该能把范围大大缩小了。等等，是分区（partition）吗？分区算法接收两个迭代器加上一个一元谓词。事实上，我目前只能想到两个算法同时接收起始、结束和中间某个位置的迭代器。等一下，我得把列表调出来。如果你正在收听节目，
I hope some of you are thinking, some of the C++ developers at least are thinking they know it in their head because it's... Oh, man. This is the suspense. I don't know. All right. Tell me. It's a rotate.
我希望你们中的一些人——至少C++开发者们——在脑海里已经猜到了，因为它是……天哪，这太让人悬心了。我不知道。好吧，告诉我吧。是旋转（rotate）。
Ah, rotate. Yes. Yes. That would make sense. Yeah, that is natural. But wait. So it is natural. Wait, what are the other algorithms that take three iterators, that take a sequence and
啊，旋转。对，对。这就说得通了。是的，这很自然。但等等。既然它是自然的，等等，还有哪些算法接收三个迭代器，接收一个序列然后再接收序列中的一个迭代器？我脑海里能想到的只有 `std::rotate` 和 `std::nth_element`。是的。我想大概就只有这两个了。也许还有 `rotate_copy`？对，`rotate_copy`。不过，严格来说它接收另一个序列作为输出序列。如果算上那些带有后缀前缀扩展的版本的话，好吧，我其实——
then an iterator into the sequence? So the two off of my top of my head were std rotate and std ent element. Yeah. I think those are the only two. Maybe rotate copy? Yeah, rotate copy. Well, no, technically it takes another sequence, but the output sequence. If there's any of the suffix prefix extensions, yeah, I don't really –
我主要指的是基础版本。不过，是的，如果你在听这个播客，而且还知道其他的，欢迎在节目发布时在推特上@我们。所以你认为，是的，`rotate` 是一种类似于“反转”的算法。但不仅于此。我不得不认为，这绝对是肯·艾弗森有意为之的安排。
I'm thinking more the base ones. But, yeah, if you're listening to this podcast and you know an extra one, feel free to ping us on Twitter when this goes out. But so you think that, yes, Rotate is a kind of reverse-ish algorithm. But there's even more. And I have to imagine that this is intentional on uh ken iverson's um part that it's more than just it's a reverse a reverse ish algorithm rotate rotates implementation is extremely linked to reverse do you know why uh and here's the here is the beauty of apl because because I learned this from APL.
它不仅仅是一个“类似反转”的算法。`rotate` 的实现与“反转”紧密相连。你知道为什么吗？这就是APL的精妙之处，因为我是从APL中学到这一点的。
Like I learned this from APL. Rotate is implementable in terms of three reverses. Oh, yeah, that kind of makes sense. In fact, I would not be surprised if the c plus plus stood rotate implementation is implemented in terms of three reverses you're given your we'll call it uh you know f for the begin uh l for the end and m for the midpoint reverse f to m reverse m to l and then reverse the whole thing. F to L. You're done. Yeah. That is, that is a rotate. That's, that's quite a, I, I, I learned that like you could implement stood rotate one of, you know, it's gotta be one of, you know, everyone has a soft, uh, a place in their heart,
就像我从APL中领悟到的一样。`rotate` 完全可以通过三次“反转”来实现。哦，对，这确实说得通。事实上，如果 `std::rotate` 的底层实现就是通过三次反转来实现的，我一点也不会感到惊讶。给你一个区间——我们称起始为 `f`，结束为 `l`，中点为 `m`——先对从 `f` 到 `m` 进行反转，再对从 `m` 到 `l` 进行反转，最后对整个区间从 `f` 到 `l` 进行一次反转。大功告成。是的，这就是旋转。这真的是一个——我是在学到这一点之后才发现你可以用三次反转来实现 `std::rotate`。这在每个人心中肯定都有一席之地，
um, for stood rotate ever since, you know, Sean parent, uh, in his C plus plus seasoning 2013, um, talk, you know, uh, 2013 talk, you know, reduces his example down to a std rotate and a find if. But like I had never really thought about the implementation of std rotate. And then from messing around with APL and trying to like learn why are there, you know, why does one choose the dyadic and monadic names or sort of algorithms for each of the glyphs? And there's so much thought and meaning put into it.
自从肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）在2013年的C++ Seasoning演讲中，把他的例子简化为一个 `std::rotate` 和一个 `std::find_if` 之后，大家对 `std::rotate` 就充满了好感。但我以前从未真正思考过 `std::rotate` 的底层实现。直到通过摆弄APL，试图去理解为什么每个符号要选择那样的双目和单目名称/算法，我才发现其中蕴含了如此之多的思考和深意。
And I don't know. Some people might be listening and thinking, okay, this just seems like a bunch of nonsense. That's not really that important but like so much of it like once once you once you learn uh the apl glyphs um honestly like so much of it just becomes like it's it's it's literally like the title of the the turing award speech notation is a tool of thought like you you learn the stood algorithms uh the algorithms in the stood algorithm header um and you you start to think in terms of you know uh rotates and reverse and and um you know ant elements and transforms and stuff like that and it's like going and learning apl is just an extension of that except instead
我不知道。有些人听了可能会觉得：好吧，这听起来只是一堆废话，没那么重要。但事实上，一旦你学会了APL的符号，老实说，很多东西就会变得豁然开朗。这简直就像图灵奖演讲的标题《记号法是思考的工具》所说的那样：你学习了标准算法头文件里的算法，然后你开始用“旋转”、“反转”、“第N个元素”、“变换”之类的方式去思考；而去学习APL只是这种思维的延伸，只不过
of having to spell out you know std colon colon each of the algorithm names it's a single it's a single click of a button on your key or a key on your keyboard anyways digression over i don't know how we started talk all right we were talking about languages not in english and apl is the closest one to that um and that yes there there is a lot there is a huge barrier to entry uh for anyone that sort of sees apl um and i yeah i'll keep i'll keep my my biggest reveal although maybe the rotate the stood rotate is the biggest reveal from from the talk that i wanted to give um but yeah it's there's just so much um in the language that i just find just absolutely like mesmerizing like take and drop are two algorithms that we got in C++20 with the range views.
不需要拼写出冗长的 `std::colon::colon` 每个算法的名字，它只是你键盘上的一个按键，或者屏幕符号的一个点击。好了，题外话到此为止。我不知道我们是怎么聊到这儿的——好吧，我们刚才在讨论非英语语言，而APL是最接近这种理念的语言；而且对于任何初次看到APL的人来说，确实存在着巨大的准入门槛。不过——好吧，我会保留我最大的爆料，虽然 `std::rotate` 可能已经算是我原本准备的演讲中最重磅的爆料了。但真的，语言中还有太多东西让我感到绝对的着迷。比如 `take`（取）和 `drop`（丢弃）是我们在C++20中通过范围视图（range views）引入的两个算法。
And those exist in almost every functional programming language. Take is an up arrow in APL and drop is a down arrow. And for me, having like symmetry in, you can't really call it the name of the algorithm in APL because it's a glyph, but there is absolute symmetry vertically between the take and the drop. Whereas in functional programming languages and now C++20 range views, you have to know that like take and drop are sibling algorithms. Like they go together. Take with a number on a range basically takes the first n elements,
它们几乎存在于所有函数式编程语言中。在APL中，`take` 是一个向上箭头，`drop` 是一个向下箭头。对我来说，在APL中——虽然你不能真正叫它算法的名字，因为它是一个符号——`take` 和 `drop` 在垂直方向上具有绝对的对称性。而在函数式编程语言以及现在的C++20范围视图中，你必须硬记住 `take` 和 `drop` 是兄弟算法，它们是天生的一对。在某个范围上调用带有数字的 `take` 基本上会获取前 `n` 个元素，
whereas drop removes the first n elements. So they are basically like the opposites of each other. But like take and drop, if you don't come from the functional programming land, it's not immediately obvious what those do. And I think in certain languages, they actually don't use take. If I'm not mistaken, some languages use skip for take. Whereas in APL, it's unmistakably like those two algorithms are related to each other. Anyways, I haven't let you speak for a while, so. There's nothing I love better than hearing you ramble about APL.
而 `drop` 则会移除前 `n` 个元素。所以它们基本上是彼此相反的操作。但是，如果你不是来自函数式编程的世界，`take` 和 `drop` 到底是干什么的，并不能一眼看出。而且据我所知，某些语言中甚至不用 `take` 这个词，有些语言用 `skip` 来代替 `take`。但在APL中，这两个算法之间存在着无可否认的内在关联。不管怎样，我已经好一会儿没让你说话了。没有什么比听你滔滔不绝地讲APL更让我开心的了。
I have a question for you, though. Putting my programming language standards hat on, there is one of the ISO programming languages which has been translated into other languages, and there is an official version in other languages with keywords in other languages. Can you guess which language it is? I did once go through all the ISO languages. This is a long shot because I don't think this is actually like officially an iso language i think it went part way through the process and then froze is it ruby it is not ruby no
不过我有个问题想问你。如果戴上我的“编程语言标准评审”帽子来看，现有的ISO编程语言中，有一门语言已经被翻译成了其他语言，并且拥有带有其他语言关键字的官方正式版本。你能猜到是哪门语言吗？我曾经把所有的ISO语言都过了一遍。这希望不大，因为我觉得这其实并不是一门真正意义上的“官方ISO语言”，它似乎在流程走到一半时就被搁置了。是Ruby吗？不是Ruby，不是。
it's an it's an older language is it ada it's not ada you're you're close though alphabetically close to ada alphabetically close to ada alg Alphabetically close to ADA. ALGOL? Yes, ALGOL 68. So ISO, which is the International Organization for Standardization, and ISO is not an acronym. It's not the International Standards Organization. It's the International Organization for Standardization. ISO used to be, I think it used to be like the acronym in French,
这是一门更古老的语言。是Ada吗？不是Ada。不过你猜得很近，按字母顺序排在Ada附近。按字母顺序排在Ada附近。ALGOL？是的，ALGOL 68。所以ISO，也就是国际标准化组织（International Organization for Standardization），而且ISO并不是一个缩写词，它不是“国际标准组织”（International Standards Organization）。它的全称就是国际标准化组织。ISO过去常常——我想它过去在法语中是一个缩写，
but now it's just, it's just like the name. And I believe it comes from like a Latin word, which, oh boy, I'm being a bad, a bad ISO person that I don't remember it off the top of my head. Um, uh, but, uh, yeah, so it's the international organization for standardization and, um, uh, the main languages of ISO are English, French, and Russian. Um, oh yeah. The, the name, uh, uh, ISO is derived. It's not Latin. It's Greek. It's, it's derived from the Greek word isos, meaning equal. So it's not an acronym. Don't think it's an acronym.
但现在它只是，就像是个名字。我坚信它来自一个拉丁词，哦天哪，我作为一个ISO的成员太不合格了，我居然没能脱口而出。嗯，呃，但是，呃，是的，所以它是国际标准化组织，而且，呃，ISO的主要语言是英语、法语和俄语。哦，对。这个名字，呃，呃，ISO是衍生出来的。它不是拉丁语。它是希腊语。它，它是从希腊语单词isos派生出来的，意思是相等。所以它不是一个缩写。不要以为它是一个缩写。
But there's multiple different ISO official languages, English, French, and Russian. And standards are allowed to be translated into some other languages too. Now, it's very rare for sort of programming language or technical standards to be published in a language that's not English, which is sort of the primary language. But ALGO 68 was published in Russian, German, French, Bulgarian, and Japanese. And the standard was also available in Braille.
但是有多种不同的ISO官方语言，英语、法语和俄语。标准也允许被翻译成其他一些语言。现在，像编程语言或技术标准以非英语（可以说是主要语言）的语言发布是非常罕见的。但是ALGOL 68曾以俄语、德语、法语、保加利亚语和日语发布。并且该标准也提供盲文版本。
And it wasn't just the standard itself, like the keywords were also translated. So this is like a Russian version of Algo where all the keywords are, you know, in Russian and Cyrillic. And I wonder whether it's actually been implemented in these other languages. But the fun fact, we could technically have the C++ language standard in other languages. And I think that there's some ISO thing that says that, yeah, we're supposed to translate it into French. We never have, but it's a thing that could happen. You could have French C++. You could have Russian C++. That's interesting.
而且不仅仅是标准本身，连关键字也被翻译了。所以这就像是Algo的一个俄语版本，所有的关键字都是，你知道的，用俄语和西里尔字母书写的。我不知道它是否真的在这些其他语言中被实现过。但有趣的是，我们在技术上完全可以用其他语言来编写C++语言标准。而且我认为有些ISO的规定说，是的，我们应该把它翻译成法语。我们从来没有这样做过，但这是一件可能发生的事情。你可以有法语的C++。你可以有俄语的C++。这很有趣。
And there is another family of languages which I think lend themselves well to being internationalized. What would you think that would be? Let's see if we have the same thought here. A family of languages? Yeah. That lend themselves well to being internationalized.
并且还有另一个语言家族，我认为它们非常适合国际化。你觉得会是什么？让我们看看我们是不是有相同的想法。一个语言家族？是的。非常适合国际化的那些语言。
Yeah. I don't... Well, by family, do you mean, like, you know, sort of the language families, like the ones that we mentioned? Erlang, Smalltalk, Forth, Algo. I consider it a language family. I don't know if it's a language family in whatever formal definitions you'd come up with.
是的。我不知道……好吧，说到家族，你的意思是，你知道的，那种语言家族，就像我们提到的那些？Erlang，Smalltalk，Forth，Algo。我认为它是一个语言家族。我不知道在无论你提出的什么正式定义中它算不算一个语言家族。
But, yeah. I honestly don't know. I don't know what... I would assume if I was thinking a language that is best suited to be internationally translated, it would be one with a small set of keywords. Right. So how about like a Lisp language like Scheme? Lisp languages not only tend to have a small set of keywords, they give you a great degree of flexibility to define domain-specific languages, to define your own operations. And they have very powerful macro systems.
但是，是的。老实说我不知道。我不知道什么……如果我要想一种最适合进行国际化翻译的语言，我会认为它应该是一组拥有少量关键字的语言。对吧。那么像Lisp语言比如Scheme怎么样？Lisp语言不仅往往拥有一组很少的关键字，它们还为你提供了极大的灵活性来定义领域特定语言、定义你自己的操作。并且它们拥有非常强大的宏系统。
In some ways, I like to think of Lisp languages as not necessarily being languages, as being sort of like a language for expressing a language. So I think you could take Scheme and you could define, you could redefine macros or functions for, or aliases for all of the sort of core functionality using a lexicon from a different language.
在某些方面，我倾向于认为Lisp语言不一定只是语言，而更像是一种用于表达语言的语言。所以我认为你可以拿来Scheme，然后你可以定义，你可以重新定义宏或函数，或者为所有核心功能定义别名，使用来自不同语言的词汇表。
And then that could be an internationalized version of Scheme. I think that's pretty true for most of the Lisp languages. It's probably also true for Haskell, I think. Well, so I guess the thought in the back of my head is when you say internationalize, does that include libraries? Because I think actually I'm not I'm not a schemer, but I am more familiar with Racket, which is basically an evolved scheme. And then Closure, which is a modern scheme or a modern lisp by Rich Hickey and both of those have quite large I don't know if they're standard libraries definitely Clojure's comes with like a core Clojure core which has
然后那就可以成为Scheme的一个国际化版本。我认为这对于大多数Lisp语言来说都挺对的。我想这可能也适用于Haskell。好吧，所以我想我脑海中浮现的想法是，当你提到国际化时，这是否包括库？因为实际上我认为我不是，我不是一个Scheme的使用者，但我对Racket更熟悉，它基本上是一个演进后的Scheme。然后是Clojure，它是一个现代的Scheme，或者说是由Rich Hickey创造的现代Lisp，这两者都有相当大的，我不知道它们是否算是标准库，绝对地，Clojure带有一个像核心Clojure核心这样的东西，它拥有
a ton of algorithms Clojure's a very beautiful language and so like internationalizing Cloj closure i would assume would would mean um also coming up with translations of the the yeah and that would be a lot more work i mean one of the nice things about the scheme is a very minimal language it doesn't really have anything like a library um which is why i which is why i picked it as a candidate there. Yeah. Have you ever in your career come across code comments, non-English code comments in a project you're working with? Yeah. Well, so not a project,
大量的算法。Clojure是一门非常优美的语言，所以把Clojure国际化，我猜这意味着，嗯，也得弄出那些，是的，翻译，那将会有多得多的工作。我的意思是，Scheme的好处之一是它是一门极简的语言，它实际上没有任何类似库的东西，……这就是为什么我，这就是为什么我把它选为候选者的原因。是的。在你的职业生涯中，你有没有在合作的项目中遇到过代码注释，非英语的代码注释？是的。好吧，所以不是在一个项目中，
but if you do any amount of competitive coding at some point in your career, whether it's just for fun or not. On a lot of websites, there's a ton of just international folks from all over the world that are competing. And so I've seen comments in Japanese, I've seen comments in Chinese, I believe I've seen comments in Russia, Russian. I don't believe I've ever seen like variable names, but like a lot of the competitive coding, like you can import like in C++, you can just copy and paste some file with a ton of macros for like's just for i that you just need to pass a single number to it that hard codes your start of your index at zero and then goes up to less than the number that you pass in. It's obviously like a terrible coding practice. But like when speed is the name of the game, it can help you write your solutions faster. And a lot of those like copy and pasted things have like comments in whatever language
但是如果你在职业生涯中做过任何数量的竞技编程，无论是不是为了好玩。在许多网站上，有大量来自世界各地的国际友人在一起竞争。所以我见过日语的注释，我见过中文的注释，我相信我见过俄语的注释。我不认为我见过变量名，但是很多竞技编程，比如你可以导入，就像在C++中，你可以直接复制粘贴一些包含大量宏的文件，比如，只是为了i，你只需要传一个单一的数字给它，它把你的索引起点硬编码为零，然后一直增加到小于你传入的数字。这显然是个糟糕的编程实践。但是当速度至关重要时，它可以帮你更快地写出解决方案。并且所有那些复制粘贴的东西都有各种语言的注释，
the individual is familiar in speaking. I've seen it in, back when I was working in high performance computing, I came across some code where, that I was supposed to port where the comments were all in Chinese. And I remember being quite happy because typically there's no comments in a lot of HPC codes and there's like single letter variables for everything.
是个人熟悉的语言。我见过它，在我过去从事高性能计算工作时，我遇到过一些代码，我需要去移植，那里的注释全都是中文的。我记得当时挺高兴的，因为通常很多HPC代码里都没有注释，而且所有东西都是单字母变量名。
So I was like, okay, I can't read these comments, but I appreciate that they're here at least. And you translate them. I don't think I needed to. I don't remember what the outcome was, but I don't think i needed to i think i don't remember i don't remember what the outcome was but i don't think it translation was necessary i do remember one time seeing um uh identifiers that were like french like it was in c++ so um i think it still like ASCII'd but they were like they were French
所以我当时想，好吧，我看不懂这些注释，但我很感激它们至少在这里。然后你翻译了它们？我觉得我不需要。我不记得结果是什么了，但我觉得我不需要，我想我不记得了，我不记得结果是什么了，但我觉得翻译并不是必须的。我确实记得有一次看到，嗯，嗯，类似于法语的标识符，它是用C++写的，所以，嗯，我想它仍然是ASCII码，但它们就像是法语的
and that reminds me of another amusing language related programming thing which is so I work a bit with the EDG C++ compiler front end which is
这让我想起了另一个有趣的与语言相关的编程趣事，那就是——我经常使用EDG C++编译器前端，它是一个
it's a proprietary front end that you can license from this company EDG C++ compiler front end, which is, it's a proprietary front end that you can license from this company, EDG. And it's a very, it's a very nice little code base. There's one interesting quirk of the code base, which is all of the data types, like the data type for a node type, it's not called struct node. It's called struct anode. Or the data type for an enum is called struct anenum. Because whoever originally structured this code base wanted all of the types to not just be the noun of what they were, but to have the, whatever you call A and an, um, and, uh, I, I think if it was like a singleton type, it would be called like struck the singleton. Um, and it was, it's just, I, I, it was so, it was so I've never seen anything like that. It's so unique. So actually I have, um, it's possible that the individual, um, is taking inspiration from small
这是一个专有的前端，你可以从这家公司授权获得，EDG C++编译器前端，它是一个专有的前端，你可以从这家公司EDG授权获得。它是一个非常，非常精美的小代码库。代码库有一个有趣怪癖，就是所有的数据类型，比如节点类型的数据类型，它不叫 struct node。它叫 struct anode。或者枚举的数据类型被称为 struct anenum。因为最初构建这个代码库的人希望所有的类型不仅是它们本来的名词，还要带有，无论你管A和an叫什么，嗯，呃，我，我想如果它是一个单例类型，它可能会被称为 struct the singleton。嗯，而且它，这太，我从未见过这样的事。它是如此独特。所以实际上我，嗯，这个人可能是从Small
talk. Um, so in my, in my small talk learnings, uh, it's very idiomatic for, in fact, like if you, that's small talk is it's a wonderful language to, to work in. Um, you basically are immersed into a small talk world. Currently, the world that I live in when I code Smalltalk is called Pharaoh, but there used to be ones called Squeak. And it's basically this like full-blown IDE with just amazing functionality. But like typically, you write your unit tests, you click like run, and then it'll fail and say, oh, this method doesn't exist. And so it gives you an option to create it. And so you click Create, and then it'll stamp out basically the signature
中汲取了灵感。嗯，所以在我的，在我的Smalltalk学习中，这非常符合习语，事实上，如果你，那是Smalltalk，它是一门极好的语言，去使用它。嗯，你基本上沉浸在一个Smalltalk世界中。目前，我写Smalltalk时生活在其中的世界叫做Pharo，但过去曾有过叫Squeak的世界。它基本上是一个功能惊人的全功能IDE。但通常情况下，你编写单元测试，点击运行，然后它会失败并说，哦，这个方法不存在。于是它给你一个创建的选项。所以你点击创建，然后它就会基本上打印出签名
and any variables if it takes sort of arguments. And the name of the arguments, it can tell. Like if you're taking a string, it will say, you know, name of your method, colon, A string. And if you look at the standard – well, I'm not sure if it's standard library, but if you look at the libraries that comes with Pharaoh and the Smalltalk language, a lot of them use like A stream or A string or an integer to name the arguments or the parameters that are being being passed to um your method so that's the only other place i've seen it so potentially this person used to work in small
以及任何变量，如果它需要某种参数的话。参数的名字，它可以识别。就像如果你接收一个字符串，它会说，你知道的，你的方法名，冒号，A string。如果你看标准——好吧，我不确定这算不算标准库，但如果你看Pharo和Smalltalk语言自带的库，它们中的很多都使用像A stream、A string或an integer来命名传递给你方法的参数，所以这是我见过的唯一一个其他地方，所以这个人有可能以前在Small
talk um well there's there's like there's like he's a small company there's like eight people there so uh we could just we could just ask them but i sort of like the the the myth of it i like the mystery of it you know one thing about i it. Yeah. One thing about, I wanted to mention about ALGOL too, because I didn't know this at one point. ALGOL actually stands for algorithm language, because it was initially created as a prototyping language for writing algorithms. It sort of went in a different direction. And I've always thought this was curious because for a while, I thought APL should be named, I think I mentioned this before, is that I think it should be named the algorithm programming language. Until, yeah, the remark that I made
talk工作过。嗯，那里有，就像，就像他是一个小公司，大概有八个人，所以，嗯，我们可以直接问他们。但我有点喜欢这种神话色彩，我喜欢那种神秘感，你知道的，关于我的一件事。是的。关于ALGOL，我也想提一件事，因为我曾经有一段时间不知道这一点。ALGOL实际上代表算法语言（algorithm language），因为它最初是被创造出来作为编写算法的原型语言的。它在某种程度上走向了不同的方向。我一直觉得这很奇怪，因为有一段时间，我曾认为APL应该被命名为——我想我之前提到过这个——我认为它应该被命名为算法编程语言。直到，是的，我之前发表的
earlier about operators and combinators. So it makes sense. But also too, ALGOL, if you listen to CppCast, or if you've watched any of Kevlin Henney's talks, he's one of my favorite speakers. You probably know this already. But Algol is one of the most influential programming languages ever. I don't know, like, the complete list of keywords that Algol was responsible for creating. But I believe, like, struct and a ton of like keywords uh directly come from algol um and can be traced all the way into c++ but like many other programming languages
关于运算符和组合子的评论。所以这说得通。但话又说回来，ALGOL，如果你听过CppCast，或者你看过Kevlin Henney的任何演讲，他是我的最爱之一。你可能已经知道了。但ALGOL是有史以来最具影响力的编程语言之一。我不知道，比如，ALGOL负责创建的关键字的完整清单是什么。但我相信，比如 struct 以及大量的关键字，呃，直接来自 ALGOL，并且可以一直追溯到 C++，但也包括许多其他编程语言
yeah i mean it it's um it uh uh it's really sort of the the the root of the family of imperative programming languages um like c the whole c um language of the whole c family of languages um owe a lot to algol um pretty much all a lot of people like the shell programming languages um ada python they all drew a lot of inspiration from algo um yeah it was really the first of the the imperative languages which is which is interesting given given that it that original intent of it being a um an algorithm language um because you don't necessarily think of imperative languages as being you know the ideal fit for developing pure algorithms. You'd want perhaps some sort of more functional language for that. So one thing, what was I just going to say?
对，我的意思是，它，呃，它，呃，它真的是命令式编程语言家族的根基。像C语言，整个C语言家族，都很大程度上归功于Algol。几乎所有人，比如Shell编程语言、Ada、Python，它们都从Algol中汲取了大量的灵感。是的，它确实是第一个命令式语言，这很有意思，考虑到它最初的意图是作为一个算法语言，因为你未必会认为命令式语言是开发纯算法的理想选择。对于那种需求，你或许会想要某种更具函数式的语言。所以有一点，我刚刚想说什么来着？
Yes, a lot of people refer to the C family as the algal family. I think a lot more people are familiar with C, so that's why it's, I think, more colloquially used. But if you go into literature, a lot of times they read it as the Algol family because that's really, if you trace the root of the hierarchy back, it goes back to Algol.
是的，很多人把C语言家族称为Algol家族。我想有更多人熟悉C语言，所以这个叫法在口语中更常用。但如果你去查阅文献，很多时候它们被称为Algol家族，因为如果你把层谱的根源追溯回去，它确实可以追溯到Algol。
Second thing I wanted to say is that, funny that we've mentioned now both Scheme and Algol. Scheme is actually the combination of both uh lisp and algol so the two creators of that language uh guy steel um and i believe gerald sussman sussman's one of the authors of the sick p textbook um they created that language and basically were combining algol and lisp uh so neat that we've mentioned those those two things um and then there was a third thing what was what did you just say at the tail end um i forgot it there's too many things oh god i can't hop too far up the stack um oh so here's another interesting
我想说的第二点是，有趣的是我们刚才提到了Scheme和Algol。Scheme实际上是Lisp和Algol的结合，该语言的两位创造者——盖伊·斯蒂尔（Guy Steele）以及我相信的杰拉尔德·萨斯曼（Gerald Sussman，SICP教材的作者之一）——他们创造了这门语言，基本上是将Algol和Lisp结合在了一起。所以我们提到这两点真是太巧妙了。然后还有第三点，你刚才在末尾说什么来着？我给忘了，事情太多了，天哪，我不能把调用栈回溯得太远。哦，这里还有另一个有趣的
algol fact so um when they were creating algol um uh they formed a working group on ALGOL. It was part of the, one of the predecessors for, one of the predecessor standards organizations for ISO, which I think was called IFP or something like that here. Let me look it up. Yeah, International Federation for Information Processing. They formed a working group for ALGOL, and that working group was called WG2.1. And that's amusing because C++, the descendant of ALGOL, its standards committee in ISO is WG21. So that... Not confusing at all. Yeah, that cracked me up.
Algol趣事。所以，呃，当他们在创建Algol时，他们成立了一个关于ALGOL的工作组。它是ISO的前身标准组织之一的一部分，我记得这里好像叫IFP之类的。让我查一下。对，国际信息处理联合会（IFP）。他们为ALGOL成立了一个工作组，该工作组被称为WG2.1。这很有趣，因为C++，作为Algol的后代，它在ISO中的标准委员会是WG21。所以这……一点也不让人混淆。对，这把我逗乐了。
Yeah. Well, and I recalled the thing I was going to say. You said that it's odd that for sort of designing algorithms, you might expect a more functional language. If you look at almost like all academic literature with respect to algorithms and algorithm textbooks, it's all using to determine whether basically like a set of parentheses are valid, which is a very common sort of interview question, like given left and right parentheses, determine whether it's valid. And I'm not sure if we've talked about this on this
是的。嗯，我想起我要说的事了。你刚才说，在设计算法时，你可能更期望使用函数式语言，这有点奇怪。如果你看看几乎所有关于算法和算法教材的学术文献，它都在使用……来判断基本上像括号集合是否有效，这是一个非常常见面试题，比如给定左括号和右括号，判断它是否有效。我不确定我们是否在这个
podcast before, but there's a very simple, basically convert it to one negative one, each of the left parentheses and right parentheses, do a plus scan, and then just check if at any point it goes below 0, and that it ends in a... So it shouldn't go below 0, and it should end in a 0. And if you can check those two properties on the plus scans of the 1, negative 1, you basically have a valid parentheses.
播客里讨论过，但有一个非常简单的方法：基本上把左括号和右括号分别转换为1和-1，做一个前缀和扫描（plus scan），然后检查它在任何时候是否低于0，以及它是否以……结尾。所以它不应该低于0，并且应该以0结尾。如果你能在1和-1的前缀和上检查这两个属性，你基本上就得到了一个有效的括号表达式。
So, like, in a functional language where you have a map and a scan, it's very easy to code this up. And so I submitted it. And then the response that I got was, please do not code this in a functional style. We only accept imperative styles or whatever. And I was just sort of like, this is ironic because like the most idiomatic, in my opinion, sort of way to solve this is using maps and scans, which are entirely parallelizable, which is, I think, like a huge mistake. That's another thing about APL. Not to go back to APL, but like, when you are coding your code in all these primitives,
所以，在拥有map和scan的函数式语言中，编写这段代码非常容易。于是我提交了代码。得到的回复是，请不要用函数式的风格来写。我们只接受命令式风格什么的。我当时就觉得，这太讽刺了，因为在我看来，解决这个问题最地道的方式就是使用完全可并行的map和scan，我认为这是一个巨大的错误。这又是关于APL的另一点。倒不是说要回到APL，但是，当你在所有这些原语中编写代码时，
your code is basically like inherently parallelizable. Everything's a transform, everything's a scan, everything's, you know, something that is like, trivially parallelizable everything's a transform everything's a scan everything's uh you know something that is like trivially parallelizable and when you code things in for loops and if statements like okay good luck it's like go find the thrust algorithm that that it corresponds to switch it to then and then you can parallelize your code yeah that's, like loops that you've written by hand, we provide you with a rich library of algorithmic primitives, which we know how to parallelize, and you use those to construct the algorithms that you need. There's a lot of talk in C++ about this Sean Perrin idea of no raw loops. Don't use raw loops when you could use a standard algorithm instead
你的代码基本上就是天生可并行的。每件事都是一个transform，每件事都是一个scan，每件事都是，你知道的，那种可以被平凡并行化的东西。每件事都是一个transform，每件事都是一个 scan，每件事都是，你知道的，那种可以被平凡并行化的东西。而当你用for循环和if语句编写代码时，好吧，祝你好运。这就好比去寻找与之对应的thrust算法，把它切换过去，然后你才能并行化你的代码。是的，这就好比你手写的循环，我们为你提供了一个丰富的算法原语库，我们知道如何并行化它们，你用这些来构建你所需的算法。C++中有很多关于肖恩·帕伦（Sean Perrin）“无裸循环”（no raw loops）理念的讨论。当你本可以使用标准算法时，不要使用裸循环，
because it expresses your intent clearer. And yeah, that's true. But when we're thinking about that, we're usually thinking about expresses your intent clearer to other human programmers. But there's a hidden benefit, which is when you write for each instead of a for loop, or when you write reduce instead of writing a for loop that does a reduction, et cetera, et cetera. When you use the standard algorithm, you're not just making your intent clearer to the programmer, you're making your intent clearer to the compiler. And so when you
因为它能更清晰地表达你的意图。是的，这确实没错。但当我们考虑这一点时，我们通常认为它是为了向其他人类程序员更清晰地表达你的意图。然而，还有一个隐藏的好处，那就是当你编写for_each而不是for循环，或者当你编写reduce而不是编写执行归约的for循环时，等等，等等。当你使用标准算法时，你不仅在向程序员阐明你的意图，你还在向编译器阐明你的意图。因此，当你想
want to go to parallelize that code, it becomes a lot easier to parallelize when it's, oh, hey, this is just some known algorithm that has certain constraints, and I plug in these user-defined functions, and then I can parallelize it as I wish within the constraints of the algorithm, within the contracts of the algorithm. And so that's another very powerful aspect of the no raw loops idiom is that it makes your code easier to parallelize
要去并行化这段代码时，就会变得容易得多：哦，嘿，这只是一些具有某些约束的已知算法，我插入这些用户自定义函数，然后我就可以在算法的约束和契约范围内随心所欲地并行化它。所以，无裸循环惯用法的另一个非常强大的方面是，它使你的代码更容易并行化、
and to vectorize and to just optimize in general. I think that's a point that like in one of Sean Perrin's talks, what now like C++ part in three vignettes, he explicitly points that out. The recorded version has very poor audio, but I think I highlighted it in one of my talks where he says when you use these abstractions um you can do later like a code review and figure out oh yeah like we would have a huge performance win if we parallelize this and then all you have to do is just swap in your serial algorithm for a parallel algorithm with the same name and you're done exactly um talk about a low low barrier to whatever performance improvement. Yeah.
向量化，并且总体上更容易进行优化。我认为肖恩·帕伦（Sean Perrin）的一次演讲中——现在是C++的三部短片里的哪一个来着——他明确指出了这一点。录制版本的音频非常糟糕，但我认为我在我的一个演讲中强调过这一点，他说当你使用这些抽象时，你以后可以做代码审查，然后发现“哦，是的，如果我们并行化这个，性能会有巨大的提升”，而你所要做的就是将你的串行算法换成同名的并行算法，然后就大功告成了。完全正确。这可以说是把性能提升的门槛降到了极低。是的。
Anyways, I feel like we're, we've been talking for like an hour now. Yeah, these were, oh, and you know, we, we, I'm going to, you're going to have to cut this into the beginning, but we have to remind our viewers about the APL drinking game that every time Connor mentioned APL during this episode, you were supposed to take a shot of eggnog. This was, This was rich. It's rich from coming from two people that don't drink. That our podcast has a drinking game associated with it.
无论如何，我觉得我们，我们已经聊了一个小时了。是的，这些是，哦，你知道，我们，我们，我打算——你得把这个剪到开头去——但我们必须提醒观众关于APL的喝酒游戏：在这期节目中，每当康纳提到APL，你就得喝一杯蛋奶酒。这真是……真奢侈。对两个不喝酒的人来说，我们的播客居然还有一个与之相关的喝酒游戏，这太奢侈了。
Yeah. Remember when we started this and we said these episodes were going to be 20 to 30 minutes? Well, so up until now, every episode has been between 30 and 40 minutes. And I thought it was going to be a nice goal to try and always do it between 30 and 40. This one, I think, definitely is going to be over 40 minutes, probably closer to an hour. Yeah, I've got an hour and 20 here. Well, I think this has been good. This has been fun.
是的。还记得我们刚开始做这个的时候，说过每期节目大概20到30分钟吗？好吧，直到现在，每期节目都在30到40分钟之间。我曾觉得，每次都尽量控制在30到40分钟之间会是一个不错的目标。这一期，我猜肯定会超过40分钟，可能接近一个小时。是的，我这里显示的是1小时20分钟。好吧，我觉得这挺好的。这很有趣。
Oh, yeah. Well, this was supposed to happen at the beginning where we read feedback, but we've got a very nice, lovely... We're doing the beginning at the end. That's fine. Yeah, maybe I'll rearrange it. Maybe I won't. We got a very nice piece of feedback from...
哦，对。本来这应该在开头念听众反馈环节进行的，但我们有一条非常棒、非常可爱的……我们在结尾做开头部分。这没问题。是的，也许我会重新排列一下，也许不会。我们收到了一条非常棒的反馈来自……
I apologize once again for the pronunciation. David Yastremki, who says, really like how your and Bryce's flow has developed through the episode. This may have been my favorite episode yet, referring to episode four, especially hearing you both reason about why different algorithms would work and the implementations.
我再次为这个发音道歉。大卫·亚斯特雷姆斯基（David Yastremki），他说：非常喜欢你和布莱斯（Bryce）在本期节目中逐渐形成的聊天节奏。这可能是我最喜欢的一期节目了（指的是第四期），尤其是听到你们两个推理为什么不同的算法会有效以及它们的实现方式。
We'll take a little time this month to give Haskell a try. It'd probably help with the functional pieces of C++ as well. And I responded, thanks for the awesome feedback. It's awesome to hear. And I've heard from many non-Haskell devs that learning Haskell has improved the way that they code in their day-to-day programming language. And what was his name?
我们这个月会花点时间尝试一下Haskell。这可能对理解C++中的函数式部分也有所帮助。我回复说：感谢精彩的反馈。听到这个感觉太棒了。我从许多非Haskell开发者那里听说，学习Haskell改善了他们日常编程语言的编码方式。他叫什么名字来着？
David Yastrzemski. Yeah, yeah, I chatted with him too um yeah yeah so awesome that uh we're getting better or at least we're not getting worse that's the key thing we're not getting worse we make we make no promises to the sponsors that we don't have yeah um well um uh i guess uh happy holidays and uh happy new year to everybody and uh yeah i guess we we may do one more episode wait what's it's next week i guess there might be another episode will be released on january 1st so this is the last episode of 2020 yeah this is the last episode of 2020 but there will be an episode next week thank god 2020 yeah almost over i'm i'm done with this year
大卫·亚斯特雷姆斯基（David Yastrzemski）。对，对，我和他聊过。嗯，太棒了，我们正在变好，或者至少我们没有变坏，这是关键所在——我们没有变坏。我们对没有赞助商的赞助商不做任何承诺，对。嗯，好吧，我想……祝大家节日快乐，新年快乐！是的，我想我们可能会再做一期节目。等等，下周是什么时候？我想1月1日会发布另一期节目，所以这是2020年的最后一期节目。是的，这是2020年的最后一期节目，但下周还会有一期。谢天谢地，2020年终于要结束了。我对这一年真是受够了。
hopefully 2021 fingers crossed yeah fingers crossed yeah it's gonna be a good year good year yeah hopefully we did we did publish a you know the larger the most uh substantial revision of c++ in a decade this year so there's that that's true maybe well we're supposed to do our parallel scan podcast episode but maybe maybe next episode we can uh do uh well we'll think about it but we can try and do a 2020 in review and find the highlights in the midst of the year that was 2020 and see if we can reflect and be positive about the things that did happen. You know, we had Prague. Prague was nice. Prague was a good committee meeting. Yeah, that was pretty good. Yeah, I got to see the Herb Sutter, Tony Vaniard, and Bjarnus Drusup, a vast meetup.
希望2021年……双手交叉祈祷。是的，双手交叉祈祷。这将是个好年头，好年头。希望如此。我们今年确实发布了十年里C++最大、最重大的修订版，所以也有这一层。确实如此。也许，我们本来应该做平行扫描播客节目的，但也许下一期我们可以……我们会考虑的，但我们可以尝试做一期2020年回顾，在经历过2020年的种种混乱之中寻找亮点，看看我们能否反思并对真正发生的事情保持积极态度。你知道，我们有布拉格（Prague）。布拉格很好。布拉格是一次很好的委员会会议。是的，那相当不错。是的，我还见到了赫伯·萨特（Herb Sutter）、托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd）和比亚尼亚·斯特鲁斯特鲁普（Bjarne Stroustrup）的大型聚会。
It was awesome. So, yeah, there were some good things. There were some good things that happened in 2020. Yeah, definitely. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and Bryce and I wish you a safe and happy holidays and a Merry Christmas. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了。所以，是的，有一些好事发生。2020年确实发生了一些好事。是的，绝对的。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，我和布莱斯祝大家度过一个安全快乐的假期和圣诞快乐。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。